right here do you have any embarrassing
stories
so as you all know we did have a fight
in our front yard when I was a teenager
uh by the way for those of you who
haven't heard that joke it's not a real
fight no no like a fight fight but it
wasn't a fight because I won but that's
I mean in my defense you were unable to
move in the front yard when the
sprinklers went on so and I was inside
eating something yeah I mean so I don't
know
so we did also actually Spar once when I
was probably 9 18 or 19. so
people had asked since the joke have you
guys gotten the ring again I was like no
because we were never in the ring but
maybe it'd be fun to go in and Spar for
a little bit look first of all guys
you know he's in better shape than I am
and so
I there was one point so that I had
never had the headgear on and it was
hard to breathe has anyone ever put that
gear on any spark it's just it's just
hard it's harder to breathe right and so
I'm in here and at one point I was just
went like winded
after I'd hit you three times
I lean into him and I go and camera's
over here right and I go
I'm pretty sure I want to throw up
so do you know what he did
he
pushed me away
and punched me right in the face
I didn't want to get throw up on me man
I was just trying to redirect your head
somewhere else it's exactly what I would
have done too yeah there's no shame and
I was like that's so funny and [ __ ] up
at the same time
2014 just to make it to another 24. got
me constantly smoking I'm getting high
just to balance out the nose
[Music]
know how to Story Goes never take
another dollar holla 7 P.M once again
I'm breaking up the bus 145.99